thousands of people gathered in an
Airfield in Kinshasa to celebrate Mass
with Pope Francis
he's visiting Democratic Republic of
Congo with the message of Peace
in a world disheartened by violence and
War Christians must be like Jesus
as if to insist on the point Jesus told
the disciples once more peace be with
you
about half of Congo's nearly 100 million
people are followers of the Roman
Catholic Church in the midday he didn't
put anyone off its sweltering here out
on the tarmac of the runway but people
here really want to hear what Pope
Francis has to say who are you
Catholic church has been a powerful
critic of Congo's rulers since the 1970s
president Felix chiseketti wanted to run
for a second term in the elections due
at the end of this year the opposition
and the Catholic church say there are
already problems with the electoral
process
the leader of the Catholic church in
Congo addressed the pope about it
the people welcoming you today is a
people suffering in its body and soul
your visit takes place during an
election year we hope to see transparent
inclusive and peaceful elections
after the mass Pope Francis met
survivors of Congo's armed conflict
including those who've been raped and
mutilated
I make a heartfelt appeal to all the
people that orchestrate War and the
Democratic Republic of the Congo in
order to plunder and destabilize the
country you are enriching yourselves
through the brutal sacrifice of innocent
victims enough stop getting rich from
money stained with blood
Pope Francis next stop is South Sudan
where he's due to travel on Friday
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Kinshasa
Democratic Republic of Congo